I'm sure you want to have a party for
Stella don't you think maybe we should
just be although I wish we had a party
for your dad when he let me put him to
sleep baby
need the game this is everyone I love
and Ron actually means dark night last
year to party she never called me back
what Jack saw this girl that he was in
love with on the train today she never
called him Becky there I'm sure she had
her reasons
[Music]
take your shoes off over there the
floors are like imported from the
ancient Roman ruins okay
that's for the invited guests Oliver you
can't have any do you want it back
[Applause]
Hey
becoming a Stella celebration Sunday
something wrong with that right
yeah let's celebrate our dog died hey
you never see him at its worst tell your
mother I just asked whether you're the
type of woman that man wanted to bang a
man wanted to marry so where did you say
you kid right come on I thought it was
just gonna be you me and Stella you may
be friends you can't go out on a school
night later mom young man old man you
spoiled the boys you're not learning how
to be men she makes these other girls
look like flying monkeys and Wizard of
Oz I'm just really really happy
something bad happened to your mom
don't go near that girl again no matter
how much you like her where'd you go to
sleep we love you smella
and M doesn't even look like it see it's
okay you still I can't read mom I liked
you so much I like you so much I'm
always worried about girls liking you
better but she had the choice that she
chose me could be awkward
[Music]
well you guys have this so precious and
beautiful that's the story yep
so much depressing story I've ever heard
in my life
you